So, this is a quadratic equation essentially. We're trying to find the zeros.
Salman Khan's disembodied voice is heard every day...
...by tens of thousands of students around the world...
...who are hungry for help learning math.
He has posted 1,200 lessons on YouTube,...
...lessons that appear on an electronic blackboard, and range from basic addition...
...and advanced calculus,...
...to science and finance.
And they are free.
Introduction to trigonometry,...
...this is where I teach people about the trig functions.
This is one of the more popular videos.
This has 179,000 views.
And you know, this is just what sine, cosine, and tangent are.
Salman Khan lives in California, Silicon Valley...
...with his wife, a rheumatologist in training at Stanford University,...
...and their new baby.
He got the idea for Khan Academy four years ago...
...when he taught a young cousin how to convert kilograms to grams.
With Khan's help, the cousin got good at math,...
...and Khan launched a new career.
Two plus two is four.
Now, Khan records his lessons from a converted closet in the back of his bedroom.
He never goes on camera.
It kinda feels like the voice in their head.
You're looking at it, it kinda feels like someone's over your shoulder talking in your ear,...
...as opposed to someone at the blackboard that's distant from you.